what is going on with this long island
housewife this is a fun
story out of long island new york
uh and it concerns our favorite things
long island
and real estate
and mental illness our third favorite
thing
can you bring that up paul
this uh
there's there's havoc in uh the long
island realtor community uh i mean if
you think kiev is bad
this woman's really causing issues here
this is a
long island woman who is going to
open houses in long island and refusing
to leave and threatening the other
buyers
and do i understand that correctly yeah
because it's a it's a taboo if you're at
an open house you don't sit on the
people's furniture you're not supposed
to sit on the people's furniture and
you're not really supposed to talk oh
really you're not supposed to
make
pronouncements loudly
you're supposed to have quiet
conversations
and then you know it's good
it's good form
to go and chat outside
if you bring your realtor to the open
house okay
you know you go outside and you have a
chat
you don't walk through and go this
kitchen
agents sometimes have to pay the bouncer
at showings
you never know who's going to show up
when homes are open to the public so the
professionals have to keep cool and take
action
this is funny
there was
a line for this showing a five bedroom
two and a half bathroom in three village
long island
i think we had like 32 sets of buyers
each with an agent easily 100 people it
was in a very desirable neighborhood a
great school district and the house had
lots of potential this was before covet
so we didn't have restrictions on how
many people could go in at one time
i had my associate joe working inside
the house trying to keep the flow going
i was outside meeting and greeting and
trying to keep up with everything pepe
try to keep everything peppy so nobody's
annoyed that they have to wait then joe
came out and pulled me aside and said
we've got a problem
there's a woman inside who is refusing
to leave
she has parked herself on the couch and
is telling people that this is her house
i went inside to find out what's going
on i can hear somebody with a raised
voice downstairs where the main living
area is
i go down and here's this woman
just sprawling there
one arm up
on the buck on the back of the camera
back of the couch
she was wearing like a moo moo
she reminded me of my mother
people were asking her are you the owner
and she was saying no but i'm gonna be
i like it
i catch her answering a question about a
feature of the house
it was a teenage girl who was asking is
this the only bathroom on this floor
i hear this woman say yes it is
sweetheart
and it's not enough for you you're a
teenager you need more bathrooms you
should look somewhere else
i walked up and i said hi
are you okay
she said why would you ask me that
i explained that i work for the seller
normally people don't sit on the owner
church furniture during an open house
it's like using the bathroom you just
don't do it and she says
quote all these people are wasting their
time and then she yells because i will
outbid you
i said my job is to make sure everyone
has an opportunity to see the house and
i think you might be making some people
feel uncomfortable she says no i'm not
and then this guy who is also there for
the open house goes the hell you're not
why don't you stop flapping your mouth
long island
joe my associate stuck his head in the
door and i told him
not to let anyone else in
i had to look
i had to stop the can we make this
bigger is there any way we can make it a
little could you zoom in paul
thank you
uh i'm like taking an eye test here to
try to read no one on gas digital reads
anything so there's no one's ever had to
bring up anything
to read
um
the funny thing is she never put in an
offer of course she didn't she was nuts
i like that i like the idea of a woman
sitting on a couch threatening people
and scaring them
and and then because she's because you
the thing about open house is you can't
really stop people from going in and
causing a real problem
and that there's something still
very democratic about that idea that
anybody can walk into any house that's
being sold and start an issue
and there's not much you can do about it
at this point you know um
so i'm all for that i'm all for uh
open house problems
because realtors are their entire job is
to be fake nice
that's their entire job
the most difficult thing about a
realtor's job
is being fake nice
all the time to everyone and realtors
notoriously
hate when
they have to
deviate from that
psychopathic
personality trait
that they have that they've developed
where they just remain fake nice
throughout all of their
daily interactions
and then when they go home they they
become
you know mr hyde again
and then the next day it's dr jekyll
hello
natural light indoor outdoor bedrooms
bathrooms isn't it nice and realtors
have to have their their job is made up
only of small talk
you will never have a disc you'll never
look at a realtor and go i have cancer
everything
that you every interaction you have with
a realtor is small talk
and fake nice small talk so what happens
to these people
is when something interrupts that
fake
world of pleasantries
and niceties and meaningless
inane
[ __ ]
it is the gravest
offense to them like when anybody comes
in from outside to start a problem and
there they realize you're like i can't
i have to now
like show
really because this is upsetting me and
i'm angry and i want this to stop
but i'm also this person this creation
that that just wants to talk about
nonsense with these idiots
and someone's on the couch yelling and i
have to be stern and
angry and get her out of here and
they're just like [ __ ]
what do i do i have to be a human being
and they're like but my entire job
is to not be a person is to be a a
creation you know
a realtor is like um you know when
they're good at it
they're a prostitute kind of you know
like you know it's like you're getting
the girlfriend experience you're getting
someone you believe cares about you and
what you do and your life and family oh
isn't oh the yard they'll run oh these
kids in that yard but really what they
want to do is just make enough money to
bail their son out of jail
but they can't
they can't tell you that
because like anything else
all of these relationships exist
um out of necessity they are
things that need to happen and they just
should be nice
while they happen so i'm all for like
fat women
sitting on couches screaming
because there's nothing better than
seeing a nice person fake nice
nothing better than seeing like a fake
nice person have to like you can see the
moments they almost have like a seizure
they're like
what are you doing like they they're
like losing they're like they're like
it's like at the end of cinderella where
they you know the carriage becomes the
pumpkin like they're reverting back to
their form and they're like oh what are
you
people people don't usually sit on the
furniture
people on youtube
and then you see them and they just
start melting and melting and
you know and again realtors for the most
part are not terribly bright
so they're not really good at problem
solving not the really high-end ones the
one i'm using now is phenomenal and
she's like a legend but the vast
majority of realtors are incredibly
stupid people who are very bad at
problem solving much like agents the the
vast majority of agents and managers are
incredibly stupid and incredibly bad at
their jobs these are jobs that you can
be very bad at because the vast majority
of people at the job are also bad
and it's actually an agreed upon thing
that we're all going to be bad at this
we're going to be bad at it together
and that's why everybody can be bad at
it because there's almost an unspoken
rule unwritten rule
that
bad is good
and slightly above bad is great
so if you're a manager in the
entertainment business and you're not ab
you're not an abject failure you're the
best it's ever been
you're great and they will write books
about you and make movies about you
because the vast majority of people in
it are so incapable of performing the
menial day-to-day tasks of a job
that to be even slightly better than
that is to win the day like an agent to
be
slightly better than the general
bad
is to be great and that's kind of like
realtors if you are just slightly better
than the vast majority of like part-time
divorced housewife
uh people that are you know trying to
make a quick buck that have no idea what
they're talking about if you're even
slightly better than that
you're in